>> Carla Hayden: Good morning.
I'm Carla Hayden, the
Librarian of Congress,
and I want to welcome you
to this very special
story time at the library.
I love reading; don't you?
It's so much fun to let
our imaginations run wild.
We're excited to be teaming
up with Miss Dolly
Parton's Imagination Library
to introduce you to
some wonderful authors
who will share their
stories with us.
Miss Parton's work through
her Imagination Library
is awe-inspiring.
She and her team have given
away over 100 million books
to help encourage young readers
like you across the world.
Here at the Library of
Congress, we share that passion
for developing young readers
and we know that the best way
to encourage people like you
to read is to make reading fun,
so that's what we're here to do.
I hope you enjoy
today's story time.
Even more, I hope you keep
reading at home and having fun.
Today we will warm up by singing
some songs, touching your toes,
and then get comfortable and
get ready to hear stories.
Now let's get started.
>> Caroline Quandt: Welcome,
everybody, to the Library
of Congress for our 6th Dolly
Parton Imagination Library
Story Time.
We're so happy you could
join us, and you at home.
So my name is Caroline Quandt.
We're going to be
featuring today,
since tomorrow is
the beginning of --
is our annual National Book
Festival, we're featuring two
of our authors, Matt de la
Pena and Danica McKellar.
So, but let's first start
with our hello song,
and we do some sign with it,
so the sign for hello is
you do a little salute, yes,
and then the sign for friends,
we're going to sing "Hello,
Friends" to the tune of
hello -- "Goodnight, Ladies,"
and there is signs, so the sign
for friends is you
take your index fingers
and you hug them one way
and then the other way,
and then it's time, you're going
to touch your imaginary watch,
and then to say, you touch
your mouth, and then hello.
Hello, friends, hello,
friends, hello, friends,
it's time to say hello.
One more time.
Hello, friends, hello,
friends, hello, friends,
it's time to say hello.
Great job, okay.
Let's do our classic "Open, Shut
Them" to wake up our brains.
Open, shut them,
open, shut them,
give a little clap, clap, clap.
Open, shut them,
open, shut them,
put them in your lap, lap, lap.
Creep and crawl them,
creep and crawl them,
right up to your
chin, chin, chin.
Open up your little mouth,
but do not let them in.
One more time.
Open, shut them,
open, shut them,
give a little clap, clap, clap.
Open, shut them,
open, shut them,
put them in your lap, lap, lap.
Creep and crawl them,
creep and crawl them,
right up to your
chin, chin, chin.
Open up your little mouth,
but do not let them in.
Good job. All right.
So let's welcome our first
author, Matt de la Pena,
to come up and read
his wonderful book,
Last Stop on Market Street.
>> Matt de la Pena: Just going
to grab the book right here.
>> Caroline Quandt: Okay.
[applause].
Here we go.
>> Matt de la Pena: Hello,
guys, how are you doing?
I'm excited to read to you from
Last Stop on Market Street.
C.J. pushed through the church
doors, skipped down the steps.
The outside air smelled like
freedom, but it also smelled
like rain, which freckled C.J.
shirt and dripped down his nose.
He ducked under his
nana's umbrella saying,
"How come we got to wait for
the bus in all this wet?"
"Trees get thirsty,
too," his nana told him.
"Don't you see that big one
drinking through a straw?"
C.J. looked for a long
time but never saw a straw.
And by the way, if you, little
guys, if you can see the straw
that that tree is drinking from,
then you understand
the entire book.
But we won't get into that now.
From the bus stop, he watched
water pool on flower petals,
watched rain patter against
the windshield of a nearby car.
His friend Colby climbed
in, gave C.J. a wave,
and drove off with his dad.
"Nana, how come we
don't got a car?"
"Boy, what do we need a car for?
We got a bus that breathes
fire, and old Mr. Dennis
who always has a trick for you."
The bus creaked to a
stop in front of them.
It sighed and sagged and
the doors swung open.
"What's that I see?"
Mr. Dennis asked.
He pulled a coin from
behind C.J.'s ear,
placed it in his palm.
Nana laughed her deep laugh
and pushed C.J. along.
They sat right up
front, which, by the way,
is one of the most
important lines in the book
and nobody really
talks about it.
The man across the way
was tuning a guitar.
An old woman with curlers
had butterflies in a jar.
Nana gave everyone a great big
smile and a good afternoon.
She made sure C.J. did the same.
The bus lurched forward
and stopped,
lurched forward and stopped.
Nana hummed as she knit.
"How come we always got
to go here after church?"
C.J. said.
"Miguel and Colby never
have to go nowhere."
"I feel sorry for those
boys," she told him.
"They'll never get a chance to
meet Bobo or the Sunglass Man,
and I hear Trixie got
herself a brand-new hat."
C.J. stared out the window
feeling sorry for himself.
He watched cars zip by on
either side, watched a group
of boys hop curbs on bikes.
A man climbed aboard
with a spotted dog.
C.J. gave up his seat.
"How come that man can't see?"
"Boy, what do you
know about seeing?"
his nana told him.
"Some people watch the
world with their ears."
"That's a fact.
Their noses, too," the man
said, sniffing at the air.
"That's a mighty fine perfume
you're wearing today, ma'am."
Nana squeezed the man's hand
and laughed her deep laugh.
Two older boys got on next.
C.J. watched as they moved
on by and stood in back.
"Sure wish I had one
of those," he said.
And if you can't
see in the back,
they're listening to headphones.
They probably have
an iPhone or iPod.
Nana set down her knitting.
And by the way, if your
grandmother ever sets
down her knitting, you know
you might be in trouble.
[laughter].
"What for?
You got the real-life thing
sitting across from you.
Why don't you ask the man
if he'll play us a song?"
C.J. didn't have to.
The guitar player was
already plucking strings
and beginning to sing.
"To feel the magic of music,"
the blind man whispered,
"I like to close my eyes."
Nana closed hers, too.
So did C.J. and the spotted dog.
And in the darkness,
the rhythm lifted C.J.
out of the bus, out
of the busy city.
He saw sunset colors
swirling over crashing waves,
saw a family of hawks
slicing through the sky,
saw the old woman's
butterflies dancing free
in the light of the moon.
C.J.'s chest grew full and
he was lost in the sound,
and the sound gave him
the feeling of magic.
The song ended and
C.J. opened his eyes.
Everyone on the bus clapped,
even the boys in back.
Nana glanced at the
coin in C.J.'s palm.
C.J. dropped it in
the man's hat.
"Last stop on Market
Street," Mr. Dennis called.
C.J. looked around as
he stepped off the bus.
Crumbling sidewalks
and broken-down doors,
graffiti-tagged windows
and boarded-up stores.
He reached for his nana's hands.
"How come it's always
so dirty over here?"
She smiled and pointed
to the sky.
"Sometimes when you're
surrounded by dirt, C.J.,
you're a better witness
for what's beautiful."
C.J. saw the perfect rainbow
arcing over their soup kitchen.
He wondered how his nana
always found beautiful
where he never even
thought to look.
He looked all around them again,
at the bus rounding the corner
out of sight and the broken
street lamps still lit up right
and the stray cat shadows
moving across the wall.
When he spotted their
familiar faces in the window,
he said, "I'm glad we came."
He thought his nana might laugh
her deep laugh, but she didn't.
She patted him on the
head and told him, "Me,
too, C.J. Now come on."
And the last page you see
C.J. and his grandmother,
they're at the soup kitchen,
but they're not there to eat.
They're there to serve.
Thank you guys so much for
letting me read to you.
[ Applause ]
>> Caroline Quandt: Wonderful.
Thank you, Matt.
What a wonderful book about
community and finding value
in the little things in
life and in giving, yes?
All right, so now we're going
to do an adaptation of wheels
on the bus that our
program director
at the Young Readers Center
[indiscernible] and I wrote.
So look at your programs.
[ Sings la, la, la repeatedly ]
The wheels on the bus
go round and round,
round and round,
round and round.
Oh, the wheels on
the bus go round
and round all through the town.
Oh, nana on the bus goes
knit, knit, knit, knit, knit,
knit, knit, knit, knit.
Oh, nana on the bus goes knit,
knit, knit all through the town.
C.J. on the bus, he
looks and listens,
looks and listens.
C.J. on the bus, he looks and
listens all through the town.
The dog on the bus goes sniff,
sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff,
sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff.
Oh, the dog son the
bus goes sniff, sniff,
sniff all through the town.
The guitarist on the bus goes
strum, strum, strum, strum,
strum, strum, strum,
strum, strum.
The guitarist on the
bus goes strum, strum,
strum all through the town.
Oh, the people on the bus go
clap, clap, clap, clap, clap,
clap, clap, clap, clap.
Oh, the people on the
bus go clap, clap,
clap all through the town.
Oh, the driver on the bus
says: Here's your stop,
here's your stop,
here's your stop.
Oh, the driver on the bus
says "Here's your stop"
at the end of Market Street.
Yeah, good job.
All right.
So let's -- now we'd like to
welcome up our second author,
Danica McKellar, who's
going to read one
of her wonderful
picture books on math.
>> Danica McKellar: Hello.
>> Caroline Quandt: Thank you.
>> Danica McKellar:
Hi, everyone.
[ Applause ]
I'm so honored to be here.
Thank you so much.
I'm going to read
one of my books.
It's called "Goodnight,
Numbers."
It was written by me, that's
Danica McKellar, and illustrated
by Alicia Padron, who also
just illustrated another book
that I just came out with
called "Bathtime Mathtime."
She does great illustrations,
so sweet.
So how many of you guys
know how to count to 10?
Anybody count to 10?
Yeah? You can?
Yeah? Very good.
I know my son can.
By the way, I dedicated
this book to Draco.
That's my son.
He's seven years old and
he's sitting over there.
All right, you guys, ready?
So this is a story about
getting ready for bed.
It shows lots of different
families getting ready for bed
and counting one to 10 as we do,
and on each page there's lots
of things to count
of that number.
So here we go.
One. Goodnight, one fork.
Goodnight, one spoon.
Goodnight, one bowl.
I'll see you soon.
So we're just finishing
up dinner.
What do you do after dinner?
Wash your hands, right?
Two. Goodnight, two hands.
Goodnight, two feet.
Goodnight, two ears.
So small and sweet.
Do you guys have two ears?
You have two ears?
Yeah? You have two hands?
Yeah? Me, too.
All right, Three.
So now we're going
to put away our toys.
Goodnight, three wheels.
That's on a tricycle.
Goodnight, three cans.
These are garbage cans,
because when my son was little,
he used to love playing
with garbage cans.
I don't know about you
guys, but he loved it.
You do? Yeah, they're
fun, right?
Goodnight, all trucks
and pots and pans.
And this, by the way, this is
our doggie named Spartacus.
He loves our couch.
Four. Now it's bath time.
Good, night four
paws, on the cat.
Goodnight, kitty cat.
Goodnight, four froggies
on the bathroom mat.
You see there's one,
two, three, four.
There are other things that
there are four of, too.
There are four buttons
on this cushion.
There are four little
bubbles here in this picture.
All right, now we're into that.
Five. Goodnight, five points.
Goodnight, little star.
Goodnight, five splashes.
They go really far.
Do you guys ever
splash in the tub?
Yeah? Yeah, it's splashy.
There are probably a lot more
than five splashes, right?
Yeah. Six.
Okay, now we're going to
get our PJs on, our pajamas.
Goodnight, six snaps,
going to snap that up.
Goodnight, Mr. Peach.
Goodnight, six blocks
with six sides each.
Do you guys have blocks?
You ever play with blocks?
They have six sides to them.
Next, we're going
to brush our teeth.
And this is a calendar
on the wall.
Do you know how many
days there are in a week?
Do you guys know?
Seven. All right, seven.
Goodnight, seven days.
Goodnight, whole week.
Goodnight, seven teeth
so clean they squeak.
Do you guys have
seven teeth yet?
Yeah? No? Okay, now we're
going to climb into bed.
Now it's story time
for the number eight.
Oh, how many arms
does an octopus have?
Do you guys know?
How many arms does
an octopus have?
Eight? Yes.
Goodnight, eight arms.
Goodnight, tall vine.
Goodnight, eight sides
on the red stop sign.
You guys ever seen a stop sign?
Yeah, you've seen it?
They have eight sides.
It's called an "octagon."
All right, now we're
going to get into bed.
Nine. And there's a
little mobile here
with nine butterflies on it.
Goodnight, nine butterflies.
Goodnight, nine bars.
Goodnight to the moon
and the countless stars.
There are a lot of other
things in each place.
There are nine spots
right here, nine squares.
There are actually nine
stars that you can see.
All right, anybody
guess the last number?
Yeah? Ten, yes.
All right, now we're
getting tucked in.
Ten. Goodnight, 10 fingers.
Do you have 10 fingers?
Yeah? Yeah.
Goodnight, 10 fingers.
Goodnight, 10 toes.
Goodnight to the world, and
everyone knows that numbers are
around us like really
good friends.
Goodnight to all the numbers.
Goodnight and the end.
[applause].
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
>> Caroline Quandt: Wonderful
introduction to math.
All right, so let's do
"One, Two, Buckle My Shoe."
You remember that, don't you?
So we're going to
do some gestures.
We're going to touch our toes,
one, two, buckle my shoe, one,
two, three, four, shut the
door, five, six, pick up sticks,
seven, eight, lay them straight.
Oops, I think I missed
-- let's see, let's see.
Ankles, knees, hips,
nine, 10, begin again.
One, two, buckle my shoe, three,
four, shut the door, five, six,
pick up sticks, seven, eight,
lay them straight, nine, 10,
and then the second time we
do: Big fat hen, big fat hen.
Okay, I think I messed up, too.
Ankles, knees, hips, so seven,
eight, lay them straight.
Okay, one, two, buckle my shoe,
three, four, shut the door,
five, six, lay them straight.
Oh, five, six, pick up sticks,
seven, eight, lay them straight,
nine, 10, do it again.
One, two, buckle my shoe, three,
four, shut the door, five, six,
pick up sticks, seven,
eight, lay them straight,
nine, 10, big fat hen.
Okay, sorry I got mixed up.
All right, so we're going to
continue the goodnight theme
with a little song of thanks,
and it's based on
Brahms' Lullaby.
[ Sings la-la-la repeatedly ]
We give thanks for the Earth,
for the day and the night,
for the stars and the moon and
the sun that gives off light,
for the clouds and the rain and
the [inaudible] full of grain,
for the life and the sea
and the flowers and trees.
Okay, good job.
All right, so that's all we
have for today, and if you're
in the area, do please come
to the National Book Festival.
It's a fabulous time,
all day long
at the Washington
Convention Center.
All right, so let's end
with our goodbye song,
which is the opposite of the
"Hello," and to say goodbye,
we just say goodbye, right?
Goodbye, friends, goodbye,
friends, goodbye, friends,
it's time to say goodbye.
See you again.
Bye-bye. [applause].